a very disturbing image of some notes
that Donald Trump wrote for himself
before speaking to the press yesterday
has been leaked and it's bizarre and
strange in all of the most unusual ways
this was Trump this was these were
Trump's notes before briefly speaking to
reporters before heading out to Texas
yesterday this was one of those black
sharpie notes that Donald Trump does
seemingly moving to a very very large
sharpie at this point and it really
signals something very off with his
ability to think let's take a look at
the picture it reads I want nothing I
want nothing twice
I want no quid pro quo tell szalinski
and it's the president's last name
zalenski is totally misspelled Trump has
no idea how to spell it tells Olinsky to
do the right thing this is how you know
it's really Trump's notes because he
misspelled zelinsky's name this is the
final word from the President of the US
I actually don't know what's weirder
that Trump thought this was a solid way
to push back against the impeachment
hearing claims made yesterday by Gordon
song 'land or that Trump needed notes to
remember this the fact that a president
would need these notes to say basically
I didn't do anything wrong
is weird I could understand if Donald
Trump had very specific details or facts
times dates places people's names who
are difficult to pronounce something
written down would make sense for that
but this is just I didn't do anything
wrong this is extraordinarily childish
but it also again corroborates the idea
that Trump can barely remember anything
it corroborates the allegations we've
been hearing about Trump's memory he
can't remember saying things he can't
remember being told things here now is
how it all shook out in video form once
again totally unhinged last second press
conference with the chopper going in the
background here's how Donald Trump
used those notes what do you want from
Ukraine I keep hearing all these
different ideas and theories what do you
want what do you want it was a very
short and abrupt conversation that he
had with me
they said he was not in a good mood I'm
always in a good mood I don't know what
that is he just said now he's talking
about what my response so he's going
what do you want what do you want I hear
all these theories what do you want
right and now here's my response that he
gave does gay
ready you have the cameras rolling
I want nothing that's what I want from
you great that's what I said I want
nothing I said it twice
so he goes he asks me the question what
do you want they keep hearing all these
things what do you want he finally gets
me I don't know him very well I have not
spoken too much this is not a man I know
well seems like a nice guy though but I
don't know him well he was with other
candidates he actually supported other
candidates not me came in late but
here's my response now if you weren't
fake news you'd cover it properly I'd
say to the ambassador's respond I want
nothing
I want nothing I want no quid pro quo
tell Jelinski president Zielinski to do
the right thing so here's my answer
I want nothing I want nothing even if
you don't think this guy needs to be
removed immediately
how could tens of millions of people
think that this is an even remotely
well-suited person for the presidency
like how how it when we get used to it
because we have scandal fatigue and
insanity fatigue and delusional fatigue
you know we have all the fatigue from
everything that's going on but how is it
possible that tens of millions of people
thought voting for this guy was a good
idea so listen if Trump literally said
here's why this this doesn't make any
sense
if Trump got on the phone with Sunland
and said listen I want no quid pro quo
why is even talking about a quid pro quo
why is that term being used it's like
calling your wife and saying hey listen
could you grab some chicken thighs and
Greek yogurt bananas Granny Smith apple
the only apple worth anything by the way
ice cream and listen I don't want any
shoplifting of these items from the
grocery
store okay no stealing of this stuff at
all just buy the stuff pay for it okay
it would be very weird to bring that up
unprovoked and of course the answer is
Trump didn't bring it up unprovoked
because the day that this conversation
happened news had broken and Donald
Trump had reason to get on the record
with Sunland at least in some way that
he doesn't want to do anything no quid
pro quo none of this stuff if it wasn't
tied to that it would be very weird to
bring up that you don't want a quid pro
quo the fact that he brought it up at
all makes us question the timing and the
timing of course tells us exactly why it
is that Donald Trump brought it up it's
Trump is actually citing it as a defense
it's more incriminating that Donald
Trump felt the need to get on the phone
and say these things I think Nancy
Pelosi had it right when she said Trump
is simply in way over his head here and
noticed that every supposedly
exculpatory data point or document that
is released by the Trump administration
is actually more incriminating the
zalenski July 25 phone call Trump says
you know what let's release a truncated
transcript of a part of it it's released
and it's more incriminating despite
Donald Trump citing it as exonerating he
says oh Gordon Sunland recalled that on
this particular phone call
I said no quid pro quo despite
testifying that it was a quid pro quo
let me just go out there and repeat that
hey I got right on the phone with this
guy and told him I don't want to quid
pro quo why would anyone talk about a
quid pro quo if there was no quid pro
quo going on they don't realize it is
all further incriminating and whether
there will be any consequences is a
different question which I'll address at
the top of tomorrow's show on the Friday
show